Hello Freak bitches that this,
I wrote a piece about it and national review about this,
you know,
you,
you say that the level of hatred directed toward Trump is warping Trump.
I think that it's also warping some people on my side of the aisle who are,
who are so you know,
interested in the fight that they're less interested in advancing the policies
that I'd like to see achieved.
So I think there's a whole group of people where,
let's say that Trump would just resign tomorrow,
he'd say,
you know what?
I've had it,
screw it.
I'm out.
And Mike Pence becomes president and then Mike Pence proceeds to do all the
things conservatives want them to do.
You know,
we get tax reform and we limit immigration and we do do all of these things.
But,
but he does not tweet about Mika Brzezinski is bloody phase.
I think there's a whole group of people on the right would be pissed that miss
it.
Yeah.
I think that right now,
cause it's fun.
What exactly what they want is somebody who pisses off the left more than beats
the left,
right.
Pisses them off.
If you piss off the left.
I think Obama sort of trolled some of the right into insanity.
I think there are a lot of people on our side where it's like this jerk,
he just,
he keeps saying things just to Piss us off.
And Obama did do some of that and so Trump has kind of a Twitter troll and so he
does the same thing.
We're like,
yeah,
that's awesome.
Like two days ago,
Trump or yesterday,
there was a report that Trump said that he thinks the White House is shabby.
Now I can say is somebody on the conservative right?
My entire life.
If Obama said that,
we would not let him forget that for 1000 years.
Oh,
that the White House is shabby.
I mean,
let's say it's an ass move to say that the people's house is shit.
First of all,
it's a mansion,
right?
Like in second of all,
this is the most iconic building on the face of the planet.
It,
oh,
it's shabby.
How is it chat?
What was he saying?
It was shabby.
He,
he said,
he said they were asking him why he gets his visits,
his golf courses so much.
And he said,
oh because the cause,
cause my golf courses are nicer because the White House a shabby.
But there are people on the right where like fine.
It's funny like you know,
at least he's trolling the left.
At least it's ticking them off and say guys ticking off the left is not a
substitute for defeating the left if you actually care about the feeding the
left.
Like this is one of the things that drives me nuts.
It cause my,
you know,
my life goal has been to promulgate particular ideas,
not just to piss off the left,
but I think that in the fight there are a lot of people who have fallen into the
trap of thinking these two things are identical,
right?
You pissed off the left.
That means you're winning.
It's like no pissing off the left.
Maybe part of it.
But that's not how you win.
You win by saying things that are true and if they get pissed,
they get pissed.
Well,
my good friend,
Bill Byrd did this piece about Obama back when Obama was mocking Trump and
saying the one thing that I am that you'll never be as the president of United
States.
The crowd went nuts.
You remember when he did that?
Yeah.
And Obama was saying this on stage,
and you see Trump and the audience boiling was,
you know,
big frog,
double chin,
just sitting there eating at all,
and that fucking stuck in his craw.
Okay.
There there's,
there's a whole story that came out from buzzfeed about his interaction with a
guy named Mckay Coppins reporter for buzzfeed in which Mckay was basically like
saying to Trump,
like,
you're a joke.
You're not going to run.
I think Trump ran just to,
just because he was sick of people telling him that he wasn't going to be
pressing until,
yeah.
I really think that's,
that's half of what drives him.
That doesn't mean that he cannot do good things.
I hope he does do good things.
He's the president.
I want every president to do things I like,
but you know,
he's going to have to get it under control.
Yeah.